bonsoir enfin c'est une autre journée
d'intenses bombardements d' une journée
sanglante aussi qu'est ce que vous savez
de la situation sur le terrain reste
choix s'annonce que les gens nous ont
dit avec qui on est toujours en contact
là bas ça a été une des nuits les plus
intenses des bombardements depuis le
début de cette offensive militaire les
bombardements se poursuivent à plusieurs
reprises contre la journée il ya eu
rumeurs de cessez-le-feu d'entente de
multipartite à deux reprises la masse
par la suite démenti avoir accès à
accepter un cessez le feu temporaire un
cessez-le-feu humanitaire donc les
combats se poursuivaient toujours des
tirs de roquettes aussi qui émane de la
bande de gaza plusieurs reprises et
sirènes du côté israélien ont retenti
les gens dû courir se mettre à l'abri
mais une journée lourde en pertes
humaines plus de 100 personnes du côté
palestinien une dizaine de soldats
israéliens
j'avais passé plusieurs jours dans la
bande de gaza comment ça se passe quand
les bombardements comme en souffrent les
bombardements fourrage c'est à dire que
cet intermittent en est constamment le
bond à borriello gourmi des drones qui
est constant partout on se déplace on
entend le bourdonnement de ces drones
qui survole tout le territoire parfois
il frappe
autrement ils ne font que de la
surveillance et puis ensuite dans les
secteurs où il n'y a pas d'opération
terrestre où les gens habitent encore
majoritairement à l'intérieur de leurs
maisons souvent si un bombardement doit
avoir mieux et c'est ce que l'armée
israélienne utilise comme justification
pour frapper les résidences en disant on
prévient les gens alors beaucoup de ces
gens reçoivent un coup de fil on leur
dit vous devez quitter votre maison elle
va être frappé d'une quinzaine de
minutes
et là c'est le branle bas de combat
évidemment il faut savoir que les
familles palestiniennes sont très
nombreuses
souvent c'est des résidences de
plusieurs étages où plusieurs familles
habitent tout le monde et celle de
sortir le plus rapidement possible
ramasser quelques effets personnels mais
on voit beaucoup de gens aussi qui
attendent une rue deux trois rues plus
loin qu'ils observent qui attend de voir
venir la frappe parfois ça prend plus de
15 minutes une heure une heure et quart
plus tard les bombardements arrive hélas
c des secours d'urgence qui se
précipitent les ambulances qui viennent
pour rapidement et c'est une voirie et
des blessés si les décors qui sont
enfouis
sous les décombres mais c'est un stress
qui constant les gens à l'intérieur du
territoire de la bande de gaza ne savent
plus où se mettre en sécurité il
pourquoi pour se protéger ces jeunes là
plusieurs de ceux qui ont reçu des
pamphlets d'avertissement par exemple au
début une opération encore maintenant on
distribue parfois des pamphlets par
avion ils ont gens qui devaient quitter
votre quartier va y avoir des opérations
militaires importantes
plusieurs d'entre eux se déplace dans
les écoles des nations unies qui ont été
mises à la disposition de la population
et des écoles publiques aussi mais la
plupart préfèrent d'abord trouvé refuge
chez des membres de la famille mais rien
de ce qui est une garantie de sécurité
ont levé des écoles des nations unies
qui ont été touchées certaines où il ya
eu des victimes des événements tragiques
et puis même les gens qui se réfugie
chez des parents un peu plus tôt dans la
journée mon interprète mon traducteur
avec qui j'ai travaillé pendant toute la
semaine où on était amis elle m'a envoyé
un message me disant la maison vient
d'être frappé par une frappe de drone
tout le monde va bien pas de blessés
mais on ne plus l'électricité plus l'eau
courante j'ai perdu internet aussi qui
est un lieu de communication avec
l'extérieur est essentielle pour ces
gens là il me dit nous n'avons reçu
aucun avertissement les dommages sont
importants mais dieu merci tout va bien
quarante personnes s'étaient réfugiées
chez lui pour se prémunir de ces mandats
le gouvernement israélien accuse le
hamas de se servir des civils comme
boucliers humains
est ce que vous avez pu le constater est
ce que c'est vérifiable on a posé la
question à beaucoup de gens la plupart
des gens nous ont dit que personne n'ait
leur avaient ordonné de rester à la
maison plusieurs d'entre eux est
d'ailleurs se sont réfugiés à
l'extérieur de saison intense de
convoyer plus de 150 mais je crois qu'on
est à peu près de 180 maintenant 580
mille pardons personnes qui vivent dans
ces refuges des nations unies par
exemple un nombre record par rapport à
tous les conflits armés précédent je
n'ai pas vu non plus d'un 10 en
circulant dans les quartiers dans
différentes parties du territoire que ça
se produisait ce que nous ont dit les
représentants du hamas sur cette
question c'est que on n'ordonne pas aux
gens de rester à la maison et c'est sûr
que pour nous c'est important que les
gens continuent d'habiter leur quartier
on dit on se souvient de 1948 des gens
qui ont été déplacés de leur village
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui des villes
israéliennes
pour nous c'est un c'était une
catastrophe c'est un traumatisme
important
alors on veut passer des deux
territoires donc on est 6 millions de
force personne je veux dire qu'ils sont
selon les apparences qu'elles ont selon
ce que nous avons constaté pendant notre
séjour sait pas encore quel est l'état
d'esprit des gazaouis parce qu'ils sont
sur le flux constant de cette menace je
joue cette menace constante des
bombardements et ce qu'ils en veulent
aux avancées ce qui le tiennent
responsable de ce qui se passe et ce qui
se révèle aussi ce régime d'abord et
avant tout aux israéliens c'est
peut-être le grand drame de tous confie
c'est que d'un côté comme de l'autre on
blâme 100% la partie adverse
du côté palestinien les gens nous ont
beaucoup dit ne pas nécessairement être
en accord avec toutes les positions
politiques
immunitaire du hamas mais que dans ce
cas ci dans le code cette offensive
militaire particulière il soutenait les
demandes du hamas étaient reconnaissants
on pourrait penser par exemple qui sera
en colère de voir qu'autant d'argent a
été investi dans l'armement des groupes
armés dans la construction de ces fameux
tunnel maintenant qu'israël cherche à
détruire mais les gens apprécient ce
qu'ils perçoivent comme la défense de la
population par les groupes armés le
soutien de leurs requêtes
alors on demande tout comme le hamas de
mettre fin à cette offensive militaire
mais au-delà de ça de mettre fin à tous
les problèmes que vivent au quotidien
les gens dans la bande de gaza depuis
des décennies ont vu en priorité la
levée du blocus imposé par israël depuis
2006 les aussi l'ouverture des
frontières beaucoup de gens nous ont dit
vous savez ce qu'on demande c'est de
vivre dans la dignité ont vu une vie
normale comme la vôtre vous avez le
droit de circuler de sortir de travail
et de bâtir un avenir avec vos familles
qui ne sera pas sans cesse détruits et à
rebâtir quelques années plus tard on a
l'impression qu'ici maintenant on trouve
une solution pour mettre fin à la
violence actuelle est bien quand on
remet ça peut-être dans six mois dans un
an dans deux ans si on n'arrive pas à
trouver des solutions à toutes ces
questions qui sont bien au delà d'un
confirme
vous avez vécu de l'autre côté aussi
quelques jours du côté israélien quel
est l'état d'esprit vous avez dit bon
les israéliens veulent ou hamas donc la
partie adverse mais aussi vivre sous la
menace des roquettes constamment voilà
les gens en ont assez aussi du côté
israélien
ils ont peur de ces requêtes qui sont
lancés à rythme très régulier depuis le
territoire de la bande de gaza ils ont d
alerte constante les sirènes dans les
villes qui risquent d'être touchés
heureusement le fameux don de faire qui
a été construit par les israéliens à
grands coups semblent assez efficace on
a pu préserver la vie de la grande
majorité de la population civile
israélienne mais les gens on sait
traumatisme d'entendre les cils les
sirènes pardon d'alert de devoir
abandonner tout ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire
le quotidien se mettre à l'abri dans les
abris qui ont été construits par le
gouvernement il sera mien et ça ça rend
la population très très anxieuse mais du
côté il sera lié aussi la majorité des
gens semblent prêtes à tolérer encore la
souffrance qui est ressenti très
vivement par ses pertes par exemple des
jeunes soldats dont beaucoup de très
jeunes hommes dans l'armée israélienne
qui sont morts depuis le début du
conflit 19 ans 21 ans 22 ans pour
pouvoir régler la question une fois pour
toutes comment est-ce qu'on règle cette
question une fois pour toutes d'un côté
comme de l'autre c'est la grande grande
île est dessiné cette question se pose
une dernière question demeure comment
quelles ont été vos conditions de
travail comment avez vous réussi à faire
votre travail avec prudence d'abord
parce que les bombardements nous on ne
sait pas de quel endroit va être ciblés
quel endroit ne sera pas donc c'est très
aléatoire on habitait et jusqu'ici on se
sent assez en sécurité dans les quelques
hôtels qui sont occupées par les
journalistes mais il ya des informations
maintenant qu'ils veulent que ce soit
des positions aussi qui sont utilisées
par les forces du hamas qui sont un peu
partout finalement dans le territoire de
la bande de gaza ce qui risque de mettre
en danger les collègues jours ben voilà
mais donc c'est des déplacements qu'il
faut mesurer chaque fois on avance
prudemment pour voir ce qui se passe
dans un secteur dans un autre parce que
comme les communications sont très
difficiles il faut nécessairement se
rendre sur place
allez parler avec les gens j'avais au
gué de l'interprète qui vous êtes
oui voilà amis avec qui on a travaillé
pendant toute la semaine qui fait un
travail formidable qui est un homme
dévoué est toujours présent 24 heures
sur 24
peu importe les contraintes de l'heure
de tombée canadienne parlons de travail
formidable on salue également votre
caméraman sylvain castonguay également
de retour à montréal bon séjour à
montréal
merci de d'être venu nous voir chez vous
en prie